Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So Leute, da sind wir.
Es war schon 10.50 Uhr, aber es ging nicht früher.
Ach ja Leute, wir müssen halt mal gucken.
müssen heute mal gucken nicht dass ich mein noise gate so hoch eingestellt hab ne
test test test test ok das ist die lautstärke das also wenn ich wenn ich leise also rede
geht das noise gate an und macht das ganze aus
aber hier asmr stream, ne mach ich nicht
ja ich glaube da bin ich in der regel immer drüber
also falls ich irgendwie abgehackt bin müsst ihr mir das sagen irgendwie sehe ich keine
viewer anzahl in meinem twitch warte mal ich muss mal refreshen
jawoll sehr gut jetzt gehts
jetzt gehts 69 viewer pock
ja also leute ich habe heute morgen ein bisschen auf dem tablet als ich aufgewacht bin schon
so ein bisschen aufm tablet auf youtube rumgeguckt und ich hatte ne videoempfehlung die ich unbedingt
gucken wollte und zwar oh joke gaming offie oh official nicht einfach nur irgendwie so
dankeschön twitch prime poggers
wo ist mein subscriber sound da stimmt was nicht
warte mal mein subscriber sound ist weg
findet ihr das auch so bescheuert dass man auf twitch jetzt erstens die ganze seite irgendwie
in schwarz hat und dass man auch wenn man auf ein profil von jemand geht ich war heute
morgen auf meinem profil dass man überhaupt nichts mehr sieht dass man nichts mehr sieht
eines der ersten sachen die mich interessieren bei den leuten ist immer zum beispiel wie
viel subs und wie viele followers haben sie da sieht man nicht mehr da muss man erst hier
drauf klicken total beknackt und ich verstehe auch nicht
warum das hier so komisch gemacht ist übrigens das beste was ihr installieren könnt ohne
vermisst es geht leider leider halt nur auf dem desktop das beste was ihr installieren
könnt ist das hier wir installieren das hier gerade mal wir gucken uns das mal zusammen
an das ist das beste was ihr installieren könnt hier franker franker faces in your
faces z so und wenn ihr das ganze dann refreshed das ganze so dann habt ihr hier unten das
da control panel und da könnt ihr einstellen theme beste das stellt ihr ein background
das da background das da und schon sieht das wieder gut aus das alte das alte theme geht
übrigens nicht mehr richtig das ist kaputt das müsst ihr einstellen das sieht ihr schon
mal wieder viel besser aus und dann ist auch noch eine wichtige geschichte was ihr einstellen
müsst zumindest das stelle ich immer so ein
was freund chat ok erst mal ganz wichtig man muss gifs einschalten was ist denn bin ich
jetzt total bescheuert was ist das denn das ist halt übelst übelst lange chat hier
genau highlight messages that mention you muss man einstellen dass man direkt gehighlight
wird wenn ein jemand anschreibt das ist wichtig so und dann haben wir bei die haben das umsortiert
das sieht irgendwie anders aus bei player das da müsst ihr ausschalten dass euch die
ganzen extensions nicht auf den keks gehen weil ansonsten übrigens ihr könnt auch bei
them könnt ihr auch die alte die alte schrift wieder einstellen wenn ihr die alte schrift
haben wollt dann macht ihr einfach so hier habt ihr wieder die alte schrift so bits
das kann man alles einschalten das machen wir aus dann ist der chat größer den rest
lassen wir an addons betta twitch tv muss an gif emotes animated so ich glaube das war
es im großen und ganzen ihr könnt noch ein highlight sound einstellen das mache ich allerdings
nicht an weil es immer offensiv immer auf den sack geht sound wet ja so muss man das
ganze einschalten schon ist twitter viel benutzbarer was ich noch ganz gerne macht ist bei player
bei nie passt alles gut das war es die settings die settings braucht ihr und das beste ist
wenn jetzt euer twitch wenn jetzt euer twitch mal rumspackt hier wir gehen mal auf den anderen
channel sonst ist übertrieben verwirrend wie verwirrend wir gehen jetzt hier bob ross
gehen wir jetzt mal rein wenn euer player mal wieder rumspacken sollte der spackt übrigens
ohne tv der müssen wir mal gucken den macht es nicht wenn euer player rumspacken sollte
da könnt ihr einfach hier drauf klicken dann doppelt klick und dann resetet der player
da müsst ihr nicht da müsst ihr nicht den kompletten das komplette fenster neu laden
was euer chat auch neu lädt ah ja und übrigens auch ein ganz tolles neues feature wenn ich
jetzt hier wenn ich jetzt hier in den chat reinschrei- fuck ich bin nicht angemeldet
wenn man jetzt in den chat reinschreibt irgendwas dann kann man mit feiltaste hoch und runter
das wieder aufrufen was man zuvor geschrieben hat das heißt wenn ihr eure lieblings copy
pastas einmal copy pastat habt könnt ihr einfach hier in die in die history gehen ich muss
mich anmelden ich weiß einfach in die history gehen und und guckt hoch und runter seht ihr
leute ich drücke jetzt die tast hoch und runter und da kriege ich meine meine alten chat nachrichten
auch ich bin halt nicht angemeldet guckt hier kann ich jetzt durchschalten das ist das ist
richtig gut das richtig gut ihr twitch in twitch in twitch in twitch in twitch in twitch yo
dog i put your twitch in twitch for twitch chat in in ofen ja so zumindest ganz tolle
geschichte kann ich jedem nur empfehlen besser als bei der twitch tv franka in your faces
z beste ihr könnt euch mal angucken was es sonst noch für möglichkeiten gibt man konnte
das fernste irgendwo mal größer machen ah settings new window ja ist viel viel besser
ähm ihr seht das ding hat massig viele massig viele verschiedene settings ja also ihr könnt
da wirklich twitch einstellen wie ihr wollt was auch ganz cool ist man kann einstellen
das hier zum beispiel wobei ich glaube das ist mittlerweile twitch standard dass man sich
die zeit davor anzeigen lassen kann ich weiß nicht ob das ob das jetzt die musik zu laut
oder kann die musik sich mal überlegen wie laut sie sein möchte jetzt ok also man sieht
schon das ding hat wirklich so viele optionen ihr könnt ihr könnt alles so einstellen
man kann den chat auch noch customisern was schriftart und abstände angeht das ist eigentlich
auch ganz cool man kann man konnte irgendwo sagen achso man hat für moderatoren hat man
auch quick actions das ist schöner zu moderieren aber man kann was auch ganz nice ist ich weiß
jetzt nicht wo sie das mittlerweile haben man konnte irgendwo einstellen achja das
ist auch cool das ist richtig geil also passt mal auf ich lösche jetzt mal meine eigene
message hier ne lull kann ich kann ich überhaupt meine eigene message löschen ich kann meine
eigene message nicht nicht löschen ja neue emotes ja neue emotes ne so genau ich lösche
jetzt lösche jetzt von lösche ich eine message mal und jetzt sieht man hier message deleted
normalerweise ist die weg aber mit ffz kann man drauf klicken und man sieht sie wieder
das heißt wenn ihr sehen wollt was die leute für für für bullshit schreiben dann könnt
ihr mit ffz das nachträglich gucken auch wenn es ein moderator gelöscht hat das ist dann
aber nur für euch das ist nicht irgendwie im chat oder so sondern nur für euch das
finde ich ist eines der besten features was es da überhaupt gibt die die funktion gibt
es auch bei der twitch tv und bei ffz gibt schon ewig aber was auch noch ganz nice ich
finde es jetzt nicht mal man kann den chat besser lesbar machen man kann man kann einstellen
dass die nachrichten leicht unterschiedliche farben kriegen die nacheinander gepostet werden
das heißt man kann sich viel besser viel besser unterscheiden ich finde es jetzt aber gerade
nicht weil das echt übelst
genau so das meine ich das ist echt praktisch das benutze ich in chats wo wo viel los ist
man kann man kann die emotes noch einstellen aber da nehme ich immer standard das ist praktisch
und wenn man mehr wenn man mehr text in das fenster rein kriegen will ist das auch noch
ganz coole kombi und das ist echt nice weil so kann man die nachrichten gut unterscheiden
und es passt mehr text rein in das gleiche fenster also das ist wirklich ordentlich ordentlich
poggers ja und man kann emojis umstellen was man was man verwenden will ja so ist das also
kann ich nein ich weiß nicht ob es mittlerweile link link vorschau kann also kann ich nur
empfehlen ffz beste ja ja der taster ist am start drei monate huge sub sehr nice so ich
muss jetzt erst mal steamlabs aufmachen nicht steamlabs streamlabs muss ich aufmachen ich
sehe dass ich nichts verpfeife übrigens ich lade grad ein video hoch 50 minuten modern
warfare beta fazit
steamlabs spinnt rum sagt den letzten letzten subs hat den letzten subs hat vor drei tagen
gegeben das kann ja überhaupt nicht sein letzten zwei subs gab es gerade eben 50 minuten ja
50 minuten
das hat sich eigentlich ganz gut zu ergeben weil ich hab schon x fanatics twitch prime
dankeschön pog es hat sich eigentlich ganz gut ergeben weil ich hatte ja schon ein beta
fazit auf aufgenommen und der andersion hat mich auf twitter gefragt ob ich mit ihm was
zusammen aufnehmen will da hab ich erstmal gesagt nee eigentlich kein bock irgendwie
nicht so nicht so bock und ich hab schon mit lange mit anderen leuten nichts mal aufgenommen
und so und das sagt ein bisschen und warum spackt mein twitch auf der anderen seite
so und da haben wir es mal probiert dann haben wir es mal probiert zusammen was aufzunehmen
und ich muss sagen das video ist halt viel besser geworden was ich solo auf also was
ich alleine aufgenommen habe deswegen habe ich das noch ein bisschen zusammengeschnitten
gameplay dahinter und hab es dann auch bei mir hochgeladen weil es war ja eigentlich
war es gedacht für seinen channel ich weiß gar nicht ob ihr überhaupt noch jemand kennt
der ist auch schon ein paar jahre am start aber war jetzt glaube ich die letzten jahre
nicht mehr so dabei hast du das video von westersburg gesehen zu der beat was nee was
die extreme nuke fighters was für ein video beta achso das habe ich gesehen ich hab beat
ich hab irgendwie beat gelesen das habe ich gesehen ja ja ich kann ihn da voll nachvollziehen
warum er da keinen bock drauf hat also für seinen spielstil ist auch modern warfare
eher nix übrigens ich hab vorhin bei mir auf dem tablet mal kurz angehabt und geguckt
was auf youtube so gibt was ich mir echt gerne angucken würde ist das video das geht 35
minuten ist ein black mesa speedrun allerdings kein bot speedrun sondern wirklich von spielern
als spiel allerdings segmented also nicht jetzt komplett 31 minuten am stück gespielt und
ich weiß dass half-life beziehungsweise generell source speedruns sind immer extrem geil anzugucken
deswegen würde ich mir das jetzt gerne mal zum aufwachen angucken kann ich auch mal ein
brötchen futtern dabei und mal einen t trinken ich trinke ja keinen kaffee ich bin da mittlerweile
komplett auf t transitioned und da kann ich mir das mal in eine ruhe reinhauen jetzt und
mal wenn es dabei dabei können wir schwätzen so wie wir das jeden aufwachstreben machen
also gucken wir uns das mal an und danach gucken wir noch gucken wir noch ein paar andere
sachen und danach gucken wir hier noch ein bisschen irgendwie tactical knife oder irgendwelche
sagen ich habe übrigens noch mehr wir müssen uns das neue das neue projekt von kim dort
komm angucken da hat irgendwas neues ich weiß nicht was er genau macht kein tas aber segmented
ja richtig otz im dk switch prime ok auf geht's legen wir mal los
ach der fängt später an der fängt der fängt schon an der fängt schon an zu runnen der
überspringt das intro das ist natürlich eine gute idee
also wenn ich mir andere half life spiel ich muss echt sagen ich bin begeistert wie schön
sie wie schön sie die original levels im black mesa nachgebaut haben ich hab sie ja
auch also mein let's play wer sich erinnert vor vier jahren oder so ist ja mittlerweile
fertig war ich auch immer begeistert wie schön sie die architektur vom original hingekriegt
haben das sieht echt cool aus ich denke mal also die ersten fünf minuten dürften von
dem speedrun jetzt nicht sonderlich speedy sein auch wenn es von speedy ist weil das
half life intro halt immer recht lange dauert aber gucken wir mal
guten morgen leute worum gehts in diesem stream wir gucken im prinzipen reacten wir ich glaub
das ist das modernere wort dafür wir gucken uns irgendwelches zeug anschwätzen bisschen
und wachen auf und dann schalte ich meinen 50 minuten modern warfare beta fazit frei
wenn es verarbeitet ist ich muss immer nebenbei gucken es braucht noch eine stunde zum hochladen
26 prozent erst hochgeladen geht das überhaupt noch hoch
und ich muss das mal im blick haben ob das überhaupt noch hoch lädt ja ok die zeit ist
gerade die zeit hat es gerade angepasst worden nee nee nee nee nee nicht langsamer upload
ich hab den upload gedrosselt auf 15 mbit dass ich auf jeden fall lag fry streamen kann
also eigentlich upload ich nur langsamer damit ich streben kann
ich kann immer noch den text der black mesa bahn auswendig und das meiste von was die wachen
erzählen ist wahnsinn ich hab das game so oft durchgespielt
hat er
mich gerade sehr laut genannt hat er hat er mir hat er gerade sehr laut gesagt
source speedruns sind einfach geil anzugucken erst mal ins game rein und direkt los gebunny
hoppe wow und jetzt kommen irgendwelche prop glitches noch
klar anstatt achso ist die lautstärke eigentlich ok
warte mal kurz ich mach mal wo wir schon gewesen sind
lautstärke ist ok oder und ein bisschen leiser ein bisschen lauter ist gut so
ist gut also ich weiß nicht wie freeman jedes mal late sein kann bei dem speedrun
übrigens ja aber das überlebt man
da muss ich gut die levels gemerkt haben der klitscht sich jetzt irgendwo durch oder so
ich glaube das nervt jeden halbzeit speedrun an das man das nicht überspringen kann
man kann in source in der älteren source version ich weiß nicht ob sie
neueren source version geht dann haut man den npcs auf den kopf und dann springen die
zu ihrem nächsten wegpunkt weiter habt ihr es gesehen das geht in allen source games
testing testing testing testing everything seems to be in order
Auch ein Ticken laut, oder?
Grafik sieht echt gut aus. Ja, Black Mesa sieht gut aus für ein 15 Jahre altes Game.
So können wir den Anti-Maske-Spektrometer auf 80% bringen und ihn dort halten, bis der Carrier kommt.
Sehr gut. Wir nehmen ihn von hier her.
Was macht der da? Glitscht er sich jetzt oben durch die Wand, oder was?
Ah nee, das ist einfach nur Show, weil er sonst nichts machen kann.
Ich dachte, man kann sich da schon durchglitschen, aber ich glaube, man kann sich da durchglitschen.
Das bringt plus nichts, weil die nächste Sequenz erst lädt, wenn das fertig ist.
Gleich, Leute. Wonka-Smoke.
Au!
Hier im Stuhl.
Der Speed-Fahrer sitzt jetzt da. Wann geht's los?
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie es dann weitergeht. Das ist ja noch Standard.
Das ist so, wie es jeder spielt. Fast, fast. Also außer das rumjumpen.
Man beachte, wir sind jetzt bei ungefähr, sagen wir mal, 10% oder so von der, nee, 15% von der Gesamtzeit.
Wir sind erst beim Intro. Das heißt, man kann sich vorstellen, wie schnell das das nächste Mal geht.
Das hab ich nie gecheckt, wo ich klein war. Die Sequenz gab's im originalen Half-Life auch.
Hab ich nie gecheckt, was diese Viecher wollen.
Ich check's übrigens bis heute noch nicht.
Ich glaube, die feiern dann irgendwie, weil man sie rettet oder so. Story-technisch. Keine Ahnung.
Aber wokehr ist Story?
Okay, jetzt geht's. Jetzt will er's wissen. Jetzt will er's wissen.
Ah, ach, da kann man rauf?
Irgendwie ist übelst laut auf meinem Ohr.
Sonst kriegen die NPCs erstmal wieder Dinge auf den Kopf gehauen, dass sie schneller sind.
Hast du schon mal ein PC-2-Speedrun gesehen, nee?
Mir fällt grad was auf, Leute.
Wisst ihr, was mir grad auffällt? Das sind die Typen aus Half-Life 2.
Big brain time.
Soll er erstmal das Ding auf den Kopf hauen?
Ich glaub, ich hab das nie so gecheckt, dass das die Typen aus Half-Life 2 sind.
Okay, ich glaub, ab jetzt geht's richtig los.
Ab jetzt geht's richtig los.
Erstmal Anlauf nehmen.
Okay, was auch immer.
WTF?
Ich hab doch gesagt, jetzt geht's richtig los.
Dass dann die Map überhaupt mit dem Laden nachkommt.
So wie Gordon jemals late sein kann, verstehe ich nicht.
Durch die Wand klitschen? Oder, ah, WTF, tatsächlich durch die Wand klitschen.
Ja, Source-Engines-Speedruns sind immer geil anzusehen.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
So ist das Ganze nicht gedacht.
So hat sich das der G-Man nicht vorgestellt.
Dass Gordon im Wild springend mit einer Brechstange in der Hand entgegenkommt,
als Blick es würdigt und an ihm vorbei rauscht.
Titanfall-Speedrun.
Oh, ich glaub, die haben da so viel dran gemacht.
Keine Ahnung.
Schreib ich mir mal auf.
Schreib ich mir mal auf Titanfall-Speedrun.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee, hier mal anzugucken.
WC2-Speedrun, Titanfall-Speedrun.
Muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
WC2.
Okay.
Das ist lustig, ey.
Hui, vorbei.
G-Man, piss dich, Alter.
Piss dich, Piss dich, G-Man.
Ich muss jetzt irgendwelche komischen Dinger aufschrauben.
Also ich muss sagen, der muss die Levels echt gut kennen, der Typ.
Es läuft immer noch die Musik, die normalerweise am Anfang läuft,
aber jetzt schon durch das Level halb durch.
Da ist ein Luftschacht.
Ich dachte, man müsste jetzt diese komische Rampe runter.
Ach ja, doch das hier ist, das sag ich, erinnere mich.
Jetzt muss man die Rampe runter.
Easy.
Das haben mehrere gemacht, es kann sein, aber es ist auf jeden Fall segmented.
Ja, ist es, ist es.
Oh, RIP, gleich splattert das Viech.
Äh, ist es. Ich weiß nicht mal, was gerade passiert ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, das ist blind playthrough, da hat es vorher noch nie gespielt, offensichtlich.
Aber Source Speedruns sind echt immer geil.
Oder generell Half-Life-Speedruns, kann man es echt immer gut geben.
Das ist schon Office, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist schon Office-Komplex, wobei das ist.
Da brauchst du normalerweise eine Stunde hin.
Normalerweise spielst du bis hier locker eine Stunde.
Au, Monkeys.
Hast du schon die Half-Life-Speedruns?
Die haben wir uns noch nicht angeguckt.
Was war denn das?
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, das ist noch ohne Xen.
Xen ist ja noch nicht fertig offiziell.
Oder kommt jetzt erst Office-Komplex?
Was?
Ist das irgendein Lade?
Was auch immer?
Klitsch?
What?
What the hell?
Was passiert gerade?
Durch die Wand, oder was?
What?
Das ist Big Brain, Next Level.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was passiert, aber bestimmt nicht einfach.
Okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen Speed aufbauen.
Nochmal, okay.
Nochmal durch die Wand boosten.
Auf geht's.
Schreckt.
Alter, WTF?
Poggers.
Das ist aber echt krass.
Da will ich nicht wissen, wie oft sie das gespielt haben, diesen Abschnitt,
wie das funktioniert hat.
Die Musik ist immer noch vom Office-Komplex.
Jetzt kommt das Tentakelzeug.
Einfach noch acht Leben übrig hat.
Ja, jetzt kommt das Tentakelzeug.
Das kann ja wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie überspringen.
What?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Ich muss mal kurz meine Bildchen ein bisschen kleiner machen,
weil man sieht so wenig vom Bild.
So, perfekt.
Das wollte ich mir gerade nochmal angucken.
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Man kann da einfach reinspringen?
What?
Okay, was auch immer.
Das scheint zu funktionieren.
Das ist echt Big Brain Plays.
Das Ding muss man normalerweise zusammenschieben.
Nicht zusammenschieben.
Das Ding muss man normalerweise eine Brücke drüber machen.
Und jetzt sind wir in On Rail.
Sind wir On Rail?
Nein, wir sind vor On Rail, oder?
Ja, wir sind vor On Rail.
Und jetzt klettern wir uns zu On Rail durch.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da passiert.
Jetzt sind wir am Ende von On Rail?
Nein.
Ich glaube, wir sind tatsächlich irgendwo mitten.
Wir sind bei der Rakete?
Wir sind bei der Rakete in On Rail?
Nein, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, wo wir gerade sind.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Ah, nein, doch.
Das ist noch On Rail.
Das ist noch mitten in On Rail.
Das ist das.
Ja, okay.
Das ist vor der Rakete noch.
Okay, jetzt sind wir erstmal mit der Out of Bounds rausgeglitcht.
Das ist 9 Head Big Brain IQ.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was gerade überhaupt passiert.
Jetzt ist er bei der Rakete, Klai.
What the fuck, Alter.
Krasser Scheiß.
So, jetzt kommt er ins Außenareal gleich.
Ja.
Nee.
Ach nee, hier ist er noch.
Ja, genau, jetzt kommt er rechts zur Rakete.
Jetzt rechts ist er bei der Rakete.
Wenn ich das noch irgendwie richtig erkenne, alles bei der Geschwindigkeit.
Da blickst du wirklich noch mal richtig durch.
Ja, genau, jetzt ist er bei der Rakete.
Alter, ich brauche da 45 Minuten durch.
Also, ich muss zugeben, der ist deutlich besser an Half Life als ich.
Aber der sieht so easy aus, wie der was macht.
Oder wie die das machen, weil es sind ja mehrere.
Alter, was ist das hier, Umweltverschmutzung?
Anzeige ist raus.
So arme Pyloren, ja.
Genau, da ist nicht Anzeige raus, da ist Greta raus.
Okay, jetzt weiß ich nicht, woran er gerade...
Ah, jetzt ist er im Außenareal bei der Rakete, okay.
Jetzt müsste er normalerweise die Rakete zünden, was er aber wahrscheinlich, so wie ich das hier sehe, nicht machen wird.
Sondern sich wieder durch die Wand klitscht.
Oder fast stirbt.
Den Boden stecken bleibt.
Ich glaube, den Boden stecken bleibt.
Und ohne die Raketen zu zünden durch ist.
Auch gut, alles, so kann man es auch machen.
Jetzt irgendwelche Speicherklitsch-Dinger wieder.
Ich kann mir das ja auch nur zusammenreimen, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was genau passiert.
Normalerweise, ist das jetzt nicht das hier, wo man durch die Wand fährt?
Nee, oder?
Okay, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, wo er gerade ist.
Das erinnert sich auch so schnell.
Ach, jetzt ist er...
Oh, Leute, da hatte ich, als ich klein war, vor dieser Szene hier, hatte ich übelst Angst jedes Mal, wenn ich das gespielt habe.
Hier, das mit dem Fisch.
Da hatte ich übelst, übelst MonkaS immer hier.
So jetzt gerade.
So jetzt, wo der Fisch rauskommt, da habe ich immer übelst Schiss davor gehabt, wo ich klein war.
Also klein.
Wie alt war ich, in der 14 oder so?
Schaust du Zocktoberfesten, ey?
Gar nicht, was das ist.
Was ist das für ein Face?
King Wall, ja, das klingt...
Oh!
Jetzt ist er bei den Assassins.
Kommt er jetzt zu den Assassins?
Das ist, das ist, wo die, wo, wo die Stels-Assassin-Dinger jetzt sind, ne?
Ja, jaja, genau.
Normalerweise muss man hier die Assassins bashen.
Und dann wird man gefangen genommen.
Warte ich mal pro Mord.
Ach, das ist das.
Ah, jetzt weiß ich wieder, ja.
Jetzt, genau, jetzt wirst du gefangen genommen.
Ach, man kann sich bewegen in dem Raum sogar noch.
Lustig, hab ich nie probiert.
Stirbt der jetzt?
Ne.
Okay, das ist komplett gescriptet, die sind unverwundbar.
Normalerweise spielst du drei, vier Stunden, bis du hier bist.
Drei, vier Stunden, wenn du schnell bist.
Bis hier hin jetzt.
Und das ist jetzt halt so der typische Fehler, den alle Bösewichte machen.
Anstatt den Held zu killen, schmeißen sie ihn natürlich erstmal in eine Schrottpresse.
Weil, absolut Big Brain Bösewichte immer.
Hahaha.
So, Schrottpresse.
Ich glaub, das hat jeder beim ersten Anlauf verkackt, als er das erste Mal auf live gespielt hat, die Schrottpresse.
Okay, ich frag mich, war das jetzt sinnvoll, war das Absicht, dass er den Eimer runter?
Das war Absicht, dass er den Eimer runtergespessen hat.
Wahrscheinlich will er sich irgendwo hochboosten damit oder so.
What?
What the fuck?
Hä?
Was zum Teufel, geht ab.
Der fliegt nicht mehr durch.
Aber das ist so geil anzugucken.
So, jetzt kommt normalerweise diese Parkour-Einlage.
Ja, Pog like this ist das.
Ah, richtig.
Normalerweise muss man jetzt Parkour-Stalls machen hier.
Aber ich geh mal davon aus, dass er das nicht machen wird.
Die Half-Life sind ja keine Zombies.
Oh, weggesplattered.
Wie heißen die Dinger nochmal in Half-Life, diese Zombies?
Die heißen ja glaub ich nicht Zombie, ne?
Aber die Sounds von den Dinger immer.
So, jetzt kommt nochmal Schrottpresse.
Häcksel, Schrott und Dreck-Kram.
Nicht Headcrabs.
Die Dinger, wo die Headcrabs auf dem Kopf sitzen, wie heißen die doch mal?
Heißen die vielleicht doch Zombies? Ich weiß nicht.
Wie heißen die echt Zombies? Okay.
Das haben sie richtig gut eklig hinbekommen.
Das sieht richtig nach Scheißwasser aus.
Richtig so hier nach Haufen.
Oh, Heavkirn, Resub, Switch Prime. Dankeschön, Pok.
Alter, wie gut kennt er die Level eigentlich? Niels, FPS, Switch Prime, Dankeschön.
Okay, das ist nicht der intended Weg.
Alter.
Das geht?
Ich dachte, man muss ja über den Zaun klettern und sich elektroschocken lassen.
Ist da irgendwas der intended Weg? Ja, das gerade.
So mal ab ein paar Sekunden zwischendurch ist der intended Weg.
Oder das Intro so halbwegs.
Richtig heiß wie ein Pepega hier unterwegs.
Der müsste jetzt eigentlich ein paar Wissenschaftler retten, dass das funktioniert.
Okay.
Oh, mit der Waffe jetzt geht's ab. Da kannste die übertriebene Speed zulegen.
Er lässt das CSGO surfen oder was?
Highspeed Pepega unterwegs.
So, einfach mal überlebt, weil Wasser.
Das ist doch keine Surfmap, Alter.
Wie oft er geblitzt wird.
Der hat schon Strafzettel Flatrate.
Aber kann er rauf? Okay, was? Ich bin echt beeindruckt von dem Speedrun.
Jetzt kommt das Granatending, der tritt natürlich nicht auf eine Mine.
Aha, okay.
Ja, Source Speedruns sind immer geil, das stimmt.
Okay, der schießt sich jetzt quer über den Berg, 100% und kommt genau oben am Ausgang raus.
Ich sag's euch, warte mal ab. Der schießt sich quer über den Berg und kommt genau oben an...
What the fuck, Alter.
Da komm ich mir wieder linkshändige mit zwei linken Händen Kacknug vor, wenn ich das sehe.
Dafür hast du zwei Jahre Netz... Ja!
Na gut, mein Let's Play ging insgesamt 6 Stunden oder so und der ist halt in 37 Minuten durch.
Und ich war schon relativ schnell.
Krasser Schiller.
Okay, jetzt... Ich glaub, Lambda Komplex dauert noch ein bisschen.
Jetzt kommt erst mal dieses ganze Zwischending dazwischen, ich weiß nicht, wie man diesen Abschnitt Navlife nennt.
Da, wo die Sniper und so oben am Fenster stehen.
Okay, hier oben sieht man überall Sniper drin, die nicht ownen, aber er ist zu schnell.
Okay, jetzt kommt das Lagerhaus, wo man keine Minen triggern darf, weil sonst das ganze Haus in die Luft fliegt.
Das muss er anscheinend halbwegs Intended machen, so wie es aussieht.
Okay, das ist alles Intended bis jetzt, alles Intended, alles Intended.
Zwar ist es aber so, man geht normalerweise außen rum und oben drüber über den Fahrstuhl, aber das ist jetzt immerhin alles so gewesen, wie gedacht.
Wir sollten Portal Speedruns schauen. Ja, hab ich schon ein paar geguckt, die sind wirklich nice.
Wie lang ist denn denn Titanfall 2 Speedrun?
Einfach mal mit der Mine hier rumstelzen.
So lang.
So, hab mir jetzt das Game auf Steam gekauft.
Oh, jetzt wird wieder durch die Wand geklitscht.
Wow, Raketen Freeman.
Raketen Freemaner.
Na, 80 Millionen ist ein bisschen lang.
Krass.
Echt heftig.
Aber du hast das Geld auf jeden Fall gut investiert, das ist ein super Remake von Half-Life 1.
Echt richtig gut.
Ich weiß, mir persönlich gefällt Half-Life 1 immer noch besser, weil es das erste Game war, was ich richtig lange viel gesucht und gespielt hab, 3D.
Nein, stimmt gar nicht.
Das erste 3D-Shooter, den ich richtig lange gesucht und hab.
Aber für die heutige Zeit ist das Remake auf jeden Fall mehr zu empfehlen als das Original.
Der Typ geht mega ab, ey.
Normalerweise, normalerweise, ne?
Normalerweise rennt hier so ein fettes Viech hinter dich her.
So ein fettes Viech mit Flammenwerfern rennt hier normalerweise hinter dich her.
Und du musst hier die Mörser einstellen, um das damit zu killen.
Aber das macht er nicht.
Der jumpt einfach weiter.
Mirrors Edge World Record. Ja, können wir machen.
Der geht nicht lang, oder?
Wie lang geht der?
Alles mal links.
Alter, wie der hier durchflutscht.
Keine halbe Stunde.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Mirrors Edge World Record, gucken wir uns doch an.
Alles mal links.
Oh, hier sind High-Fische.
Ne, nicht High-Fische. Wie heißen diese Fische? Die komischen Half-Life-Fische drin.
Monkeys.
Ok, erstmal schön durch die Decke kletschen oder sowas.
Ja.
Ok.
Ok, der ist jetzt einfach schon Lambda-mäßig drin.
What?
Null.
Link im Discord. Ok, danke schön.
Takes.
Die sind von mir, die Immortals.
Noch mal schön durch die Wand kletschen.
Hat's jetzt nicht geklappt oder braucht er wirklich zwei Schuss?
Ne, der braucht mehr Schuss. Das hat geklappt.
Ja, hab ich.
Plantera, der ist im Chat.
37 Minuten Mirrors Edge.
Krasser Scheiß, Alter. Ich bin echt am Staunen.
Ich bin richtig am Staunen. Der Speedrun ist wirklich cool.
Poggers Run ist das.
Autoscroller.
Moment.
Moment. Hat der gerade das gesamte Level übersprungen? Sehe ich das richtig?
Hat der gerade das gesamte Level übersprungen? Das muss ich mir gerade noch mal angucken.
Ich bin gerade von dem Zocktoberfest das erste Mal gehört und dann festgestellt, dass ich in einer halben Stunde da bin.
Du meinst jetzt Location-mäßig?
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken. Hat der gerade das ganze Level übersprungen?
Poggers. Das ist ja richtig geil.
Der hat das ganze Level übersprungen. Das dauert normalerweise eine Stunde, bis man das hat.
Calumina, 01, Switch Prime, Dankeschön, Poggers.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich was übersehen.
Nope.
Execution, Switch Prime, Dankeschön.
Der hat das ganze Level übersprungen. Ich bin echt schockiert.
Wir müssen das doch mal hier kurz huldigen, wie schön das die Black Mesa Leute hingekriegt haben. Guckt euch mal an, wie schön das Loch aussieht.
Der hat der Chat wieder. Der Chat.
Es sieht richtig geschmolzen aus.
Das geht? Das geht? Das wusste ich nicht, dass das geht. Ernsthaft?
Das geht? Man kann mit diesem Ding die Türen aufschießen?
Das ist wirklich Big Brain. Der ganze Run ist einfach nur Big Brain.
What the fuck, ey. Was sagst du um den neuen Twitch-Rap-Ui? Ich finde es von den Farben nicht schön.
Deswegen FFZ installieren und einfach eigene Farben einstellen. So, der Run ist vorbei gleich. Das ist der vorletzte Raum.
Wo er jetzt ist. Der vorletzte Raum.
Ah, Reset. Reset. Er steckt fest.
What the fuck. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was überhaupt passiert gerade. Was passiert? Was ist gerade los?
Okay, ich sehe, der klitscht sich immer ein Stückchen weiter. Wahrscheinlich... Ah, ich weiß, was passiert. Ich glaube, ich weiß, was passiert.
Der klitscht sich in den Trigger rein, wo es nach Xen geht. Kann das sein? In den Teleport Trigger, wo es nach Xen geht?
Klitscht er sich rein, kann das sein? Nee. Okay, dann habe ich keine Ahnung.
Der hat einfach den Raum jetzt davor übersprungen. Da ist sehr viel NPC und Dialoge in dem Raum vorher.
Der hat das Long Jump Modul doch gar nicht mitgenommen.
Okay, man kann 100% in den Trigger vorher reinspringen. 100%. Der macht nicht das ganze Level mit einem Lebenspunkt. Das glaube ich nicht.
Was macht der da auf die Cutscene warten?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das zu irgendwas dazugehört, dass er jetzt hier im Kreis Bunny hoppt. Der wartet einfach, bis der Fight losgeht.
Kreisel, genau. Der kreiselt. Kogas.
Oh, der macht doch den Fight, sonst würde sich nicht die Lehmung und die Sachen holen.
Im originalen Half-Life konnte man da jetzt schon reinspringen und in den Xen Trigger.
Oder Scan Teleporter.
Wie sie geschreckt werden. Gut, der weiß halt überall, wo die Gegner spawnen. Das ist der schwerste Fight im Game eigentlich.
Für ihn halt nicht. Für ihn ist das halt...
Und das ist halt mit der Armbrust.
Ha, guck mal, die ganzen Mops checken es nicht.
Normalerweise sagt der NPC jetzt, it's ready oder sowas, falls der NPC nicht geklitscht ist.
Alter, Wahnsinn. Fertig. Wahnsinns Run, ey. Wahnsinns Run. Echt Next Level Shit.
Raketen Freeman am Start.
Eine Runde Klapper in Chat, ja.
Super Mario plus Warplus. Ach, das hat glaube ich schon jeder gesehen. Können wir mal nachgucken, was wir jetzt gucken.
Wir gucken uns den neuen, weiß nicht, ob der neu ist.
Der ist neu.
Alter, 27 Minuten. Sag mal, Westersburg kann ja sein, dass der einfach 10 Minuten schneller ist als du.
Der World Record, Dude.
Okay, von... Ach so Leute, jetzt erstmal hier gucken. Wir wollen jetzt nicht nur das Zeug angucken.
Den Black Mills Accent Trailer. Ja, habe ich schon gesehen. Den können wir jetzt aber gleich nochmal angucken.
Also hier Source Runs. Okay, das ist Standard. Von Speedy.
Haben wir uns gerade angeguckt. Der Accent Trailer. Ich weiß nicht, ob es den neuen gibt.
Welchen denn?
Kim.com nicht vergessen, ja.
Wo kommen Frauen und Kinder eigentlich? Ich hoffe nicht, dass Kinder in nächster Zeit kommen.
Da habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinerlei Bestrebung nach.
Black Mills Accent Trailer vor 10 Monaten. Klar, den haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Ich hasse Kinder. Ich hasse echt Kinder. Aber ich hasse nicht nur Kinder, ich hasse vor allem Menschen.
Da gehören Kinder halt dazu. Aber ich liebe Haustiere.
Ich frage mich echt, wie die das schaffen, dass es so gut aussieht in der uralt Source Engine.
Das sieht huge aus.
Außer den Chat. Den Chat mag ich.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das sind im Endeffekt alles Half-Life Fans, die den größten Teil ihrer Arbeit kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt haben.
Mittlerweile gibt es das auf Steam, aber Black Mesa konntest du komplett kostenlos spielen.
Allerdings empfehle ich euch echt die Steam Version zu kaufen.
Erstens sind da ein bisschen weniger Bugs drin und die Leute zu unterstützen ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das ist ein Fanprojekt im Endeffekt.
Welche Farbe hat deine Katze? Weiß, schwarz, orange.
Hat die Katze RGB? Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das sieht übelst gut aus.
Ich freue mich schon, wenn das rauskommt. Jetzt gibt es ja schon die Beta.
Alter, was ein dicker Sack.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie die es schaffen, aus der Source Engine so viel rauszuholen.
Das sieht echt extrem gut aus.
Das ist die Katze.
Weiß, schwarz, orange, rot.
Verfolgst du auch Sky Oblivion?
Ne, was ist das?
Was? Source Engine hat nur Probleme mit Gesichtern?
Findest du?
Source Engine war eines der ersten Sachen, die richtig gute Gesichter hatten.
Apex ist auch Source, ja.
Titanfall ja auch, sind von den gleichen Typen.
Keine Katzencam?
Ja, weil die zum größten Teil auf dem Kühlschrank in der hintersten Ecke liegt.
Da kann ich sie nicht filmen.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns an.
Ach doch, das habe ich irgendwo schon mal gesehen.
Das habe ich irgendwo schon mal in einem Video zugesehen.
Übrigens, dass das erste Mirror's Edge einfach viel besser ist als das zweite Mirror's Edge.
Das zweite Mirror's Edge sagt, das erste ist richtig gut.
Warum kann man hier nichts Copy-Pasten?
Das triggert mich.
Ich muss Einser Copy-Pasten können.
Okay, auf geht's.
Das ist auch, also, ich habe ja schon ein paar Mirror's Edge Speedruns gesehen,
aber das ist jedes Mal auch so immer absolut hier mind-blowing Mirror's Edge Speedruns.
Alter, was ist das für sexistisches Spiel?
Hier werden Frauen geschubst, habt ihr das gesehen?
Was ist da?
Die Anzeige, direkt.
Vor allem, das Spiel sieht richtig gut aus, ja.
Also animiert, ja, aber ich finde, gerade was Mirror's Edge ausmacht grafisch,
ist einmal, dass es so glänzend alles aussieht und die Farbkombinationen sind richtig nice.
Was zum...
Okay, ich kann zu Mirror's Edge nicht so viel sagen wie zu Half-Life,
aber das Geile ist, bei Mirror's Edge Speedruns, man hat immer den Eindruck,
dass die Leute das so spielen, wie der Hersteller es gedacht hat, bloß halt noch viel krasser.
Alter, was ist mit der Wand los?
Da erkennt man überhaupt keinen Unterschied zum Rest.
Kannst ruhig was erzählen, ja klar.
Ich denke einfach, dass genauso Mirror's Edge gespielt werden soll.
Da sind ja auch relativ wenige Out-of-Bounds-Klitsche und so dabei, oder?
Also jetzt nicht, mein Half-Life war die Hälfte Out-of-Bounds.
Also, ich gehe mal davon aus, das sieht einfach aus, ne?
Das Movement, aber ich glaube, es ist saumäßig schwer.
Er klitscht alle paar Sekunden mit dem Jump, ja.
Aber ich finde halt das Geile ist, es ist im Prinzip immer noch das Spiel in der korrekten Reihenfolge,
was du halt bei Half-Life überhaupt nicht sagen kannst.
Das ist halt mega nice.
Du siehst halt einfach, dass die Leute extrem gut sind mittlerweile.
Und was bei Mirror's Edge cool ist, ist die Farbgebung.
Ich meine, keiner wird jemals ein Büro weiß-grün machen, ja.
Viele Speedrunner meinen, dass Mirror's Edge das schwerste Speedrun, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Also ich glaube, du musst da wirklich im teilweise Millisekunden-Takt auf irgendwas achten.
Ich kann das jetzt selbst gar nicht so einschätzen, weil wie gesagt, ich habe weder Mirror's Edge-Fehle gespielt,
noch habe ich das jemals auch in einer Ansatzweise versucht, das zu speedrunnen.
Aber ich finde, man sieht es auch als Außenstehender schon ein bisschen.
Okay, das ist jetzt so definitiv nicht gedacht.
Das ist jetzt so Halb-Out-of-Bounds-Klitsche.
Es ist aber auch übelst nice anzugucken.
Wie wird best possible time in bestimmt, naja, alle Segmente, also alle Best-Zeiten in den jeweiligen Abschnitten zusammengerechnet?
Also alle Best-Zeiten der unterschiedlichen Abschnitte zusammengerechnet ist ein possible best time, würde ich sagen.
Für ihn halt.
Mausrad-Jump, aaah.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Lucio in Overwatch, da hast du auch Mausrad gejumpt.
Für bessere Wall-Jumps.
Erstmal schön die Tür aufgekickt.
Zeigt mir mal einen, ich stelle mir das gerade so vor.
Stellt euch mal vor, ne?
Ihr steht im Gang, es kommen drei Leute aus dem Fahrstuhl raus
und das erste, was du machst, ist erstmal Anlauf nehmen,
Beine hochziehen bis zum Gesicht und über die drüber jumpen und in den Fahrstuhl rein.
Das sieht, falls gut animiert ist, hier so natürlich aus.
Aber stellt euch das mal in echt vor.
Okay, das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall irgendein Out of Bounds-Gedingse.
Das ist eine der Gründe, warum Konsolen-Wall-Track-or-43-Spielung ist.
Ah, okay.
Ja, Mausrad-Jump, beste.
Sag mal, hier solltest du eigentlich gar nicht runterkommen, ne?
Wenn du den Boden berührst, ist wahrscheinlich Death-Trigger.
Hier darfst du eigentlich gar nicht runter, ne? Normalerweise.
Okay, das ist jetzt so auf jeden Fall nicht gedacht.
Die Animationen sind echt nice in dem Game.
Also gut, das war jetzt ein Ladebildschirm, aber die Animationen in Mirror's Edge sind wirklich echt cool.
Es gibt, ich hab mal, ich hab in einem Video mal gesehen, Mirror's Edge,
wo sie das Ganze aus der, also nicht aus der Ego-Perspektive gemacht haben,
sondern die Kamera verschoben haben.
Also Faith ist nicht wirklich anatomietechnisch menschlich aufgebaut.
Die sieht ziemlich kaputt aus, wenn man das aus Third-Person-Sicht anguckt.
Also Faith ist wirklich greb aus Third-Person-Sicht.
Warte mal, das müssen wir uns mal kurz zwischendurch angucken, das ist echt lustig.
Ne?
Das ist alles nicht das Video, was ich meine.
Egal, gucken wir mal nachher.
Das sieht aus Third-Person teilweise übelst kaputt aus.
Die Beine klitschen rum und, also das wäre auf jeden Fall RIP.
Also ich finde, was Mirror's Edge echt ein bisschen ausmacht, ist die Farbgebung.
Gut, ich meine, ich glaube, der hat hier auch sein Gamma extrem hochgestellt,
weil so weiß ist das normalerweise nicht.
Wahrscheinlich will er einfach mehr FPS, oder?
Oder was ist das Buch, warum ist das so?
Warum sieht das grafisch nicht ganz so gut aus?
Das ist Standard-Gamma, echt sieht das echt so übertrieben, sah das so übertrieben erleuchtet aus.
Okay, was?
What the fuck?
Okay, da können sich Raketen Freeman noch was abgucken jetzt.
Der nutzt ja Glitcher aus, ja natürlich.
Bei dem Trick habe ich mich bei dir auch schon gewonnen, ja?
Übrigens wisst ihr es, wie geil das ist, 1080p 60 FPS zu streamen?
Jetzt sieht es nämlich bei euch im Stream genauso gut aus, wie bei mir im Video.
Das ist huge Pog.
Hab ich übrigens auch höchste Auflösung eigentlich?
Ah ja, hab ich.
Erstmal komplett vorbei.
Aber das Coole an Mirror's Edge ist wirklich, dass es im Prinzip,
mal die Out of Bounds Sachen ausmacht,
dass es im Prinzip vom Ablauf her ziemlich ähnlich zu dem ist,
wie es sich der Hersteller gedacht hat, nur halt 6 geile Tricks dabei.
720p in 2019.
So komme ich immer zur Arbeit.
So slide ich immer morgens in die U-Bahn Treppe.
Und ich nehme auch nicht den Fahrstuhl, sondern kletter erst mal das Regenrohr hoch.
Das mit dem 90 Grad drehen macht man, damit man immer auf Höchstgeschwindigkeit kommt.
Ja, das weiß ich noch.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Also nicht vom Spielen, sondern vom Erzählen.
PC Lustig will in FaceDM sliden.
Na dann, GLHF.
Wie lange der gebraucht hat, bis der Run perfekt ist?
Wahrscheinlich hunderte Versuche.
Weißt du das Westersburg, wie lange der da...
Wie lange der da schon spielt?
Der spielt doch bestimmt schon Jahre lang, oder?
Oder zumindest hat er einige hundert Runs drinne.
Tausende Versuche mehrere Jahre.
3000 plus Playtime.
Okay, jetzt klitscht es halt ein bisschen rum, weil man nicht da sein sollte.
Was hältst du von Studiumswirtschaftsinformatik?
Das ist das, was du machen willst.
Kann ich jetzt nichts Negatives dazu sagen oder was Gutes.
Also wenn du denkst, dass es was für dich ist, dann ist es wahrscheinlich das Richtige.
Mich kannst du mit BWL Zeugs halt jagen.
War das Absicht?
Ah, das war keine Absicht, okay.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, man könnte jetzt nochmal so 15 Sekunden locker sparen.
Kannst du nachher hitmen?
Weiß ich nicht, mal gucken.
Denkst du es macht Sinn auch Kobold zu lernen?
Ah, eher weniger.
Es sei denn du bist irgendwo, die wirklich Kobold Leute brauchen und da gibt es fette Kohle vielleicht.
Aber eher nicht.
Ich finde es geil, wie die Voice Samples oder die Sounds gar nicht nachkommen.
Vom Kick dann zum Rollen und so, das passt überhaupt nicht.
Da ist noch Luft nach oben, 21 Minuten segmented.
Ja klar, noch Second Plan. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Sieglimick überhaupt noch streamt oder ob da noch Mario spielt, ich glaube nicht mehr.
Gut ja, letztes Mal wo ich geguckt hatte, hat er RuneScape oder irgendwie sowas gespielt.
Ich meine da musst du schon lange üben, dass du die ganze Level so auswendig kennst und dann auch die perfekten Movement-Dinger am Start hast.
Weil da soll man sehr wahrscheinlich nicht hoch, planmäßig.
Level auswendig kennn, ist einfach Tricks den Schu...
Wow!
Ah, ok, das war auch nicht gewollt so.
Ja, wenn dich BWL interessiert reicht es, dann ist Wirtschafts... also wenn dich ein bisschen IT interessiert und BWL, dann ist Wirtschaftsinformatik auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Ich kann es mit BWL Zeug jagen, ja.
Ach doch, Checkpoint mit R!
Ah, ich sehe hier, wir haben hier die Bros in Chat.
Ich finde immer, man erkennt immer ein bisschen, wenn er da lang geht, wo er nicht lang gehen sollte, erstens, dass du keine Farben hast, weil Mirror's Edge hat ja immer dort Farben, wo es lang geht.
Sondern, dass die Texturen richtig scheiße sind. Wenn die Texturen richtig scheiße sind, dann weißt du, das ist meistens ein Weg, wo du nicht lang solltest.
Hat Mirror's Edge normalerweise nicht Musik?
Die haben doch einen richtig coolen Soundtrack, den hat er ausgeschaltet, oder?
Wahrscheinlich kann der Soundtrack noch so gut sein.
Wenn du das so lange spielst, geht es dir irgendwann auf den Sack.
Das war jetzt mal Absicht, oder?
Auch Fail, okay.
Gartentour? Nee.
Ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung von der Mirror's Edge Story, ich weiß nur, dass sie irgendwie ihre Schwester retten will.
Ja, weiß ich dazu nicht. Ich glaube, reicht auch, mehr muss man dazu glauben, auch nicht wissen.
Kann man nach so vielen Fails noch von einem guten Speedrun sprechen?
Naja, es ist ein Weltrekord, also der ist schon ziemlich gut, aber man sieht auch daran, dass es halt viel schneller ginge.
Aber das Spiel besteht anscheinend aus so vielen Tricks, die du perfekt machen musst, dass es wohl sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dass jemand einen richtig perfekten Run irgendwie 35 Minuten oder so am Stück hinlegt.
Vielleicht, ja klar, als Taz kannst du das schon machen, aber ich gucke mir ganz ehrlich, Taz Sachen gucke ich mir ab und zu mal an, aber ich finde das nicht so reizvoll.
Ich finde es viel cooler, wenn ich weiß, dass das jemand Menschliches erspielt hat.
Bei Taz weißt du immer, okay, es sieht geil aus, aber du weißt halt eh automatisch schon, dass jeder Trick klappt.
Ja, ein Torbrowser könntest du machen. Findet Taz der ODA, Sir.
Ja, auch so.
Ich glaube, ich habe keine Subs übersehen.
Taz, das ist, wenn du quasi den Speedrun, den Input programmierst, also wenn du die Inputs nicht selber machst, sondern quasi von einem Bot, die den Input machen lässt.
Das heißt, du kannst wirklich jeden Input perfekt timen. Du hast ja einen Skript, was für dich das Spiel spielt im Endeffekt.
Äh, machen die Dinger keinen Damage oder so?
Klar dauert das Programmier eine gewisse Zeit, und Taz zu erstellen ist ziemlich zeitaufwendig.
Und jetzt raushoppen?
Ich finde es geil, dass man davon keinen Damage kriegt, das hat mich das letzte Mal schon überrascht.
Ja, aber Mario Taz haben es ja so gemacht, dass sie den N64 Random Generator vorher mit dem richtigen Seed sieden, dass das Game immer gleich ist.
Also sie haben es ja geschafft, den Mario 64 Taz auf dem original N64 zu spielen, indem sie einfach quasi die Inputs an Controller gelötet haben.
Das ist auch voll abgedreht.
Oh!
Ach ne, die klebt sich doch aufs Dach. Man sieht gleich, dort wo die Texturen richtig beschissen sind, sollte man nicht sein.
Echt nice.
Okay, immer wenn es rote Dinger sind, weiß man wenigstens, hier sollte man normalerweise auch lang.
Ich finde es schon lustig, dass der erste Teil so viel besser ist als der zweite.
Mirrors Edge 2 hat kaum jemand gespielt und spielt irgendwie auch kaum jemand. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es Mirrors Edge 2 Speedruns überhaupt gibt.
Das stimmt, der erste ist Unreal. Ja, das war noch Pre-Frostbite für alles.
Aber daran wird es wahrscheinlich nicht liegen. Es geht wahrscheinlich eher um die Designentscheidungen, die getroffen wurden.
Die haben den Unreal für Mirrors Edge von Movement garantiert auch viel selbst programmiert. Movement sackt den Catalyst, da haben sie sich nicht richtig Mühe gegeben.
Das Oktoberfest vor drei Jahren, ich habe gar nicht mehr richtig dran gedacht. Jetzt fällt es mir wieder ein.
Die Catalyst-Speedruns sind 50 Minuten. Jetzt gucken wir danach. Danach gucken wir noch ein Modern Warfare 2 Video von Forge in Forgenate.
Das gucke ich immer gerne.
Das erinnert mich jetzt an Half-Life, Luftschachtgestellte.
Ich finde es geil, wie sie die Türen immer aufkickt.
Übrigens, dieser Sound, haben die den Sound geklaut in Modern Warfare? Hört euch das mal an.
Original Modern Warfare Tür-Sound.
Wollt es doch noch Kim.com kommen? Ja, können wir auch machen.
Der hat eigentlich wirklich Sound geklaut. Quatsch.
Hört sich aber ähnlich an, wie die Modern Warfare Tür aufmacht.
Wie ist jetzt der neue Unge für Speedruns? Wenn ich merke, wie viele Views ungemacht, easy.
Reaktisch einfach ein bisschen und gut ist.
Wobei man sagen muss, reacten ohne Webcam ist schwierig.
Hier oben sollte man auf jeden Fall nicht lang zu der Zeit. Zumindest ist der Boden übrigens geklitscht.
Face Reveal. Doch alles intended.
Ich mache mir einfach so eine Plastiktüte oder Papiertüte, schneide zwei Löcher rein und drücke vorne den Keks drauf und ziehe es mir über den Kopf.
Aber dann kann man sich das mit der Facecam auch sparen, weil dann sieht man ja nicht, wie man reactet.
Oder ich werde einfach hauptberuflicher React-Streamer, wenn ich dann irgendwann 15.000 Subs habe oder so.
Dann ist mir nämlich auch egal, ob mich Leute erkennen oder nicht.
Da gehe ich nämlich einfach nicht mal aus dem Haus, weil da habe ich genug Geld.
Ich mache einfach den ganzen Tag Reaction.
Dude.
Onks, was jetzt?
Tactical Nuke incoming.
Krass.
Also die Abläufe sind schon ziemlich optimiert von ihm.
Das ist zwar der Weg, den man laufen soll, allerdings, dass es so smooth alles funktioniert.
Ja, ich glaube, man kann sie aus jeder Höhe abrollen, wenn man es richtig macht.
Oder aus fast jeder Höhe, ne?
Ich glaube, da war was.
Oder zumindest deutlich höher, als es gedacht ist.
Danach mache ich richtig genauer, Erhan.
Danach mache ich Reactions zu meinen Reacts.
Das ist Next Level.
Das sind dann Max-Reacted zu Old Videos.
Dann Reacte ich dann zu meinen Videos und irgendwann, wenn ich lange genug Reacted habe, sind meine alten Videos auch schon Reaction Videos.
Okay, jetzt ist der Run fast fertig.
Es geht langsam aus Ende von dem Game zu.
Wobei, die größte React-Inception, die ich bisher gesehen habe, war immer noch, wo...
Warte mal, wer hat da auf wen?
Inscope hat auf Ungereacted, der auf MontanaBlack Reacted hat.
Das war echt komplett React-Inception.
Super Content, ja anscheinend schon, das gucken sich ja hunderttausende Leute an.
Ich persönlich verstehe auch nicht so genau, warum, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall Content, den Leute sehen wollen.
Und außerdem ist er schnell produziert.
Mir kann keiner erzählen, dass Reaction-Content wahnsinnig aufwendig zu produzieren wäre.
Oh, hier sollte es auf jeden Fall nicht sein, so eine Kack-Textur, wie die Autos haben.
Aber zumindest ist der Boden fest.
Okay, oder auch nicht.
Das war jetzt aber Absicht, ne?
Das ist jetzt, dass er lädt, dass er an der anderen Stelle wieder lädt.
Oh, voll in... au! Wobei, es kloppen sicher zwei Grills.
Ach du Scheiße, Patrick, das ist echt ein Ding.
Das ist ja quasi Penta-Reaction.
Die Fahrstuhlmusik, ja.
Ich frag mich nicht, warum, hat jetzt eigentlich überhaupt nichts damit zu tun.
Woopla ist Speedrunner, Half-Life Speedrunner, Mirror's Edge Speedrunner, alle eine Speedrunner.
Mario Speedrunner, Zelda Speedrunner.
Alles, alles gespeedrunned.
Ich wechsle nur immer häufig meinen Gamertag, dass es nicht so auffällt, dass ich das alles selbst bin.
Das wäre sonst zu auffällig.
Da würden mich die Leute wieder flayen, Max, no life, erst zwölf Stunden Mirror's Edge, dann zwölf Stunden Half-Life, dann zwölf Stunden Mario, dann zwölf Stunden Zelda, alles an einem Tag.
Parallel auf mehreren Rechnern.
Deswegen habe ich da überall einen anderen Gamertag für.
So sieht's aus, ne?
Ich meine, manchmal muss man auch mal da durch, ja.
Daniel Lull, Stufe 1, 3 Monate, Poggers.
300 Views, Lull.
Ja, so nice. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid.
Ich habe ein Video zu Mirror's Edge gemacht.
Allerdings hat er in der Wessersburg gespielt, nicht ich.
Emperor V1, Twitch Prime.
Danke schön, Pog.
Jetzt ist es an der Zeit mit Emperor V2 auch noch einen normalen Sub zu machen.
Und dann mit V3 einen Tier 2 Sub, mit V4 einen Tier 3 Sub.
Ich blicke selbst nicht mehr durch, was ich gerade erzähle.
Ach, jetzt ist dieses komische...
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, bei dem Video, was wir zusammen gemacht haben hier.
Habe ich euch eigentlich heute schon mal erzählt, was man mit Amazon Prime und Twitch Prime für tolle Sachen anstellen kann?
Ja, letztes Level.
Ich finde die Farbgebung, die Farbgebung ist in Mirror's Edge wirklich richtig gut gemacht.
Wow, Alter.
No second plan, Stufe 1, Pongas, danke schön.
Max FPS abends echt, sowas ist ein Ding.
Ich würde mir meine Videos nicht angucken.
Also nicht 5 am Stück abends mit Leuten zusammen.
Das wäre mir zu cringe.
Aber du bist nicht der einzige.
Also ich habe schon ein paar Comments gehabt, wo Leute gesagt haben, sie gucken sich die Videos immer zusammen machen und so.
So, jetzt kommt Final Boss, der 2 Sekunden dauert.
Ja, was kann man denn nur mit Amazon Prime machen?
Das verrate ich euch nicht, weil wenn ihr es rausfindet, bekommt ihr den Sub.
Das ist gratis.
Darüber springt man den Boss komplett?
Ja, das Heli Ding halt.
Ist ja nicht wirklich ein Boss.
Also farblich haben sie das echt schick gemacht, das erste Mirror's Edge, kann man nichts sagen.
Never Lucky, Twitch Prime, danke schön, Pongas.
So, jetzt kommt der Heli Stels, ne?
Oder muss man, ne, jetzt muss man durch den Serverraum, oder ist man durch den Serverraum schon durch?
Ne, jetzt kommt der Serverraum.
RTX AI, what?
Muss man gleich mal gucken.
Was, in 12 Monaten nur ein Sub? Was ist das für ein Scamas?
So, Drip.
Fertig, Run durch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann stoppt der Run, jetzt schon oder erst, wenn irgendwie die nächste Szene anfängt?
Ab der Cutscene, okay.
Ach ne, das ist ja die Schwester, hab ich ja ganz vergessen.
Ja, das ist ein nice Game, ein sehr nice Game.
Hier noch was lustiges für zwischendurch, ist das kim.com?
Ach das, ne, das kenn ich schon.
Der Westerburger hat noch was zum Mirror's Edge geschickt, das sind nur 30 Sekunden, können wir uns noch kurz angucken.
Bist du jetzt Saarländer, ne?
Ist das Italienisch? Ne, Spanisch?
Was ist mit dem los?
Was passiert da gerade?
Mach ich auch immer so.
So Sebaro, hast du das Video mal für das neue kim.com Projekt, was wir uns angucken wollen?
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch eine Runde Tactical Knife Modern Warfare an.
Hab ich mir auch heute Morgen schon auf dem Tablet rausgesucht, das wollte ich mir auch mal angucken.
Haha, das war so OP Shit, das war so OP Shit, Alter.
MLC legit.
Marathon Light White Commando.
I'm Sebastian Witch Prime, Dankeschön.
Das ist OP gewesen, der Kram Alter.
Alter, was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Tja, da würde ich sagen, da ist der Host geragedquitted.
Das konnte dir ja in diesen Ollen Lobbies noch passieren.
Das Video ist nicht alt, das Video ist von Ende 2018.
Ich meine, in Modern Warfare 2 war die Nuke zu einfach.
Du hast in der Regel gemacht Harrier Chopper Gunner Nuke.
Das war im Prinzip zu einfach, das hast du auch daran gesehen, dass die Leute irgendwelche Penta Nukes gemacht haben.
Aber im aktuellen Modern Warfare ist die Nuke, so wie es jetzt ist, außer mal Ground War, schöne Klitsch, Spots auf dem Dach, nahezu unmöglich, wenn du gegen gleich gute Gegner gematcht wirst.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Du musst so krass dich anstrengen, dass du überhaupt mal irgendwie einen 25 killen. Ich habe einen Gameplay noch übrig, irgendwie 25-4 oder sowas und Leute, ich habe so massiv geschwitzt, bis ich meinen Chopper Gunner hatte.
Das war nicht normal.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob mein Modern Warfare Video schon verarbeitet ist. Nee, natürlich nicht.
Damals haben Leute nicht so krass getryhardet. Nee, das liegt auch, es gab damals richtig viele schlechte Leute, das ist heute weniger, aber du hattest halt auch wirklich so Up and Down Lobbys.
Du hattest richtig gute Lobbys, da war es sau schwer, was hinzukriegen und du hattest Lobbys, wo wirklich nur Leute mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mit dem Fuß gespielt haben oder so.
Zauberst du noch Battlefield ab und zu, mal ein paar ältere, aber das aktuelle Battlefield gefällt mir halt überhaupt nicht und das Battlefield 1 war auch schon nicht so meins.
Es ist erlaubt, dass er sich umdreht. Es ist erlaubt, dass der Gegner sich umdreht, also komm.
Es ist nicht fair, Skill-Based Matchmaking. Ja, es ist fair, aber es macht für alle kein Spaß, das ist ja das Problem da dran.
Im Ranked, okay, vollkommen in Ordnung, im Ranked muss es sogar so sein, aber im Ranked hast du ja auch einen Rank dran stehen.
Wenn du einen Rank dran stehen hast, dann kannst du dir nicht auf deine KD und deine Killstreaks abrubbeln, sondern kannst sagen, guck mal, ich bin Grandmaster 4200.
Das ist dann cool, aber im Quickplay hat es überhaupt keine Daseinsberechtigung, weil Quickplay definiert sich in Konten nur durch KD und ordentliches Killstreak gebashe.
Vollkommen egal, ob man ein nächstes Lobby wieder richtig auf die Fresse kriegt, aber es ist so was, was ich da so jede dritte, vierte Lobby dabei ist, wo man halt ordentlich was ab, wo man ordentlich abgehen kann.
Es macht keiner Seite Spaß so wirklich.
Oh mein Gott, das ist jetzt so gefährlich.
Moin, Tylo.
Ich habe gerade...
Haha, oh, copy, war das gerade, war das gerade Controller?
Hat er gerade sein Controller in die Ecke geschmissen?
Hört mal.
Ich habe gerade...
Oh mein Gott, wirklich?
Wirklich?
Alles klar, Leute, also meine Stimme kann...
Meine Stimme kann oder kann nicht ein bisschen anders klingen.
Ich musste neue Astros kaufen.
Eigentlich musste ich sie nicht kaufen.
Ich musste sie nicht kaufen, weil meine anderen Astros noch unter Warranty waren.
Ach nee, das war sein Headset, das war nicht der Controller.
Ja, also wenn du dich fragst, wie sie kaputtgebrochen sind, habe ich sie eigentlich auf dem Boden gebrochen und eine der Rage-Klips, die du gesehen hast,
ein kleines Auxiliary-Kabel, das eigentlich kaputtgebrochen ist und dann einfach in das Ding gestoppt ist, also es kaputtgebrochen ist.
Ja.
Ich glaube, ich hätte mich nicht mehr glücklicher haben können, weil ich noch ein paar Astros auf ein paar $250 kosten müsste.
Aber wirklich, ein Tag, ein Tag.
Dieser Typ hat mich gesehen.
Oh mein Gott, ich bin gerade kaputtgebrochen.
Alles klar, lass uns das machen. Kann das bitte sein?
Zuerst das Spiel mit dem neuen Headset.
Ja, fang mich hier zurück, 18.
Pff, ja gut, Pech.
Ich kann es nicht mehr.
Ich würde mir auch nie Astros kaufen.
Astros fand ich, fand ich, vor allem weiß ich noch nie, warum die Leute sich Astro-Headsets gekauft haben.
Der Mix-Amp war okay.
Den habe ich heute noch.
Für Konsole.
Sorry, Kumpel.
Also Sebaro, ich habe mir gerade mal das Kim-Bot-Com-Video angeguckt.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts, was im Stream so richtig interessant ist.
Ein bisschen durchgeskippt.
Auf Wasteland stelle ich es mir schwierig vor, wobei halt Wasteland für Harrier das beste ist.
Wobei halt Wasteland für Harrier das beste ist.
Ich bin nicht auf dem Stinger. Ich gehe auf Camp und bekomme diesen Nuke.
Ich hatte genug Probleme mit diesem Tachknife.
Ich bin nicht witzig.
Oh, cool.
Ich bin weg.
Carrier, Chopper-Gunner, Nuke, das war unterm Strich, muss man sagen, war das in Modern Warfare 2 schon zu einfach, ja.
Hey Max, kannst du mir vielleicht meinen Code angucken, mir sagen, ob es leserlich oder Spaghetti ist? Klar, welche Sprache denn?
Ja, schick mal Pastebin oder so her, können wir uns angucken.
Zischab, ja schick mal Pastebin.
Stimmt, und außerdem hat Nuke das Match beendet.
Everyone's got Painkiller, dude. Oh my gosh, yo, Painkiller galore. Oh my gosh, god bless, bro. That literally took so long, I know I only got 7 kills with a knife this time around, but dude, if you guys couldn't already tell by all the rages I put in the beginning, this is a straight pain for me.
Anyways, I hope you guys didn't enjoy the video, didn't enjoy the rages, because there sure was a lot. You guys are new to the channel, be sure to subscribe, we are on the road to 100k. Drop a like on the video, let's try and break a thousand likes. Appreciate that so much, guys. Have a great day.
Oh, Unity, Tommy's Unity Code kann ich wenig sagen. Ich kann mir zwar den Zischab Code angucken, aber das ist ja relativ umfangreich. Das können wir jetzt nicht im Streben machen. Was haben wir sonst noch hier gerade? Oh ja, nice, das gucken wir nochmal. Das ist auch ein Klassiker. Das ist auch ein Klassiker.
Wobei, nee, das ist ein anderes Video, als ich gedacht habe.
Oh, das geht zu laut.
Sandy Ravage. Damals wollte jeder Videos, damals wollte jeder so abgehen wie Sandy Ravage. Und was ich auch damals nicht gecheckt habe ist halt, mega Upload, was ich damals auch nicht gecheckt habe,
ist, dass er auch nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt ist. Wisst ihr, ich dachte immer, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch da geht. Ich dachte immer, da geht jedes Game so ab. Und ich hab's nie gecheckt, dass es im Prinzip einfach nur halt ein Ausschnitt ist von den Games, wo es halt richtig gut gelaufen ist.
Das hab ich erst gecheckt, nachdem ich selbst Videos gemacht hab, dass man einfach nur die Videos eben hochlädt, die was taugen, ja.
Tech, haben wir gerade, T-Tactical Header.
Bambi, Tactical Header, Tango Sucker.
Die Waffe 2 Sounds war doch am besten.
Was hältst du vom neuen Borderlands? Hab ich nicht gespielt, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt will er's wissen. Das war das auch, was irgendwie die Sandy Ravage Videos ausgezeichnet hat.
Ah, der Herr Kraut, der haut schon echt gut rein, ne?
Der haut schon echt gut rein.
Huggers, vor allem fällt euch mal auf, dass die Leute damals auch noch zu dumm waren, irgendwie den Launcher einzupacken oder so.
Die haben alle die Kills schickslich abgeschossen.
Double Kill, Triple Kill, Multi Kill, oder? Nein, doch nicht.
Heutzutage bist du nicht mal eine Sekunde in der Luft.
Ey, wisst ihr, wie schlimm das ist in Ground War, in Modern Warfare?
Ich lade dir gerade ein Video hoch und da ist ein Ground War Gameplay dabei, wo ich dann auch einen VTOL und einen Payflow am Start habe.
Die machen jeweils irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zwei Kills, dann sind sie runtergegeiert.
Der Double Nuke, Double oder Triple Nuke gibt das dieses Video, eher Double Nuke.
Ich mein, so wie der spielt, es ist übelst glücklich, dass der nicht öfter stirbt, ne?
Darf man auch nicht vergessen, wo man wieder sieht, es sind halt einfach nur die besten Runden.
Teilweise rennt er halt übelst los und wird nicht gehitted.
Und außerdem war in Modern Warfare 2 alles irgendwie OP und konnte dich extrem schnell killen.
Wie war das? Farmers Rote Tiger Streifen Beste? Oder war das Black Ops?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo jeder gesagt hat, Alter, Allo Tricks Fake, Farmers Rote Tiger Streifen.
Wo Farmers Rote Tiger Streifen quasi für einen Spieler reserviert war, weil manche Leute irgendwie ein bisschen beschränkt waren, keine Ahnung.
Die Musik passt auch richtig geil dazu.
Na, gibt es doch eine Triple? Gibt es doch eine Triple Nuke?
Oh, der ist okay, der muss eh sterben.
Warum darf da eigentlich Metallica Musik hochladen und wird dafür nicht geblockt?
Haben die das approved?
Metallica wird nicht gesperrt. Klar wird Metallica gesperrt, ich hatte auch mal Metallica in Videos, war sofort weg.
Kann das sein, dass das Metallica Cover ist?
Der Anfang hat sich sehr Metallica-mäßig angehört.
Ja, das ist eine Metallica Best-of-Cover.
Jetzt werden sie wieder geschreckt.
3 Stück bis zur Nuke, richtig nice Gameplay. Der hat wahrscheinlich wieder seit Release gespielt und durchgesuchtet zur damaligen Zeit für dieses eine nice Gameplay. Ich weiß, er hat viele nice Gameplays gehabt, aber das ist schon eines der besten.
Der Typ hat so ein krasses... oh ne, der stirbt jetzt.
Der Typ ist jetzt ein krasser Rapper, das Angry German Kid. Der ist jetzt ein krasser Hip-Hop Typ.
Der hat einen eigenen Channel auf YouTube.
Guck mal, wie hieß der Channel nochmal?
Hercules Beats.
Da ist er doch.
Das ist er.
Der ist mittlerweile auf YouTube am Start.
Das ist so was, hätte es damals YouTube gegeben schon, hätte der mehrere Millionen... oder umgedreht, wäre das heute so angehalten wie damals, hätte der mehrere Millionen Abos. Genauso wie der Assi Tony. Hätte der Assi Tony damals YouTube-Videos gemacht, hätte der auch ein paar Millionen Abos und könnte davon leben, denn die waren einfach zu früh.
Ja, das ist okay, das ist Metallica-Cover.
Headbang Time!
Darkness, wie auch immer die Lyrics gehen. Irgendwas mit Darkness.
Dieses Aiming ist so schlimm anzunehmen, warum? Das ist halt Xbox 360, Aiming ist doch okay. Dafür ist es doch ganz nice.
Und er hat, wenigstens hat er das richtig gemacht, er hat den Controller schon nicht so schnell eingestellt, deswegen trifft er auch so gut. Die ganzen Noobs haben damals gedacht, sie müssten alle Phase-20er-Sens-Kreiselsachen anstehen, einstellen.
Sandy spielt invertiert. Ich auch. Revealed. Invertiert Beste. Nur die wahren Pros spielen invertiert. Ich kann nicht spielen ohne invertiert.
Invertiert Controller ist das Ding Beste. Ist das normal, dass es jetzt wieder von vorne anfängt?
Oh, da hab ich gerade geklickt. Ah, ich hab geklickt. Lull. Alter, Lull. Woop, Lull. So, was macht eigentlich mein Video? Ist das mittlerweile verarbeitet? Nein, 360p. Ja, fuck. Okay, naja gut. Also das Video kommt wahrscheinlich erst so 16 Uhr oder sowas, das heißt, es kann auch ein bisschen verarbeiten.
Okay Leute, wie lange bin ich denn schon on? Zwei Stunden, eine Minute. Ich hab Hunger, sag ich euch. Ich hab übertrieben Hunger.
Ich hab mich früher immer gefragt, wer invertiert spielt, bist du ein Videoklassen? Ich weiß nicht, ich kann nicht normal spielen, ich muss invertiert spielen.
Oh, was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn heute noch? When a Noob-Tuber gets taste of their own Noob-Tube? Medicine. Okay. Der Lego-Typ wieder. Spinning a Lego wheel faster.
Wir müssen uns jetzt nochmal, guck mal, ich krieg meine eigenen Videos empfohlen, Poggers. Timestamp für IT-Gehälter. Irgendwo da so.
Max, du bist ein Ehrenmann. So siehts aus.
Diese Schwarzgefahre trotz Fahrschein wird mir auch empfohlen. Moment, was? Javelin Tactical Nuke? Das glaub ich nicht. Da ist irgendein Trick dabei.
Haben wir das nicht schonmal geguckt? Der macht 7 Kills und Harrier 100 Pro. Ja klar, weil es Modern Warfare ist. Weil es Modern Warfare ist, da ging das halt.
Müssen wir trotzdem Javelin. Javelin, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken. Javelin Moab, wo wir gerade dabei sind, Leute.
Da ist der Moab, da ist der Moab.
Oh Mann.
Da ist die Moab.
Oh, da hat er aber Glück gehabt. Whoa, Alter. Übertreib halt mit deinem Intro. Was geht ab? PTF.
Alter, was ist mit dem... Ach, das ist Ali-A? Hä, warum hat der Ali-A davor gemacht? Hä? Ich glaube, der verarscht den. Ich glaube, der wollte den verarschen, den Typ.
Der wollte den verarschen. Ah, verstehe. Gibt's den überhaupt noch? Das war doch ein Meme. Ich kann nicht jedes bescheuerte Meme kennen.
Ich kenne schon mehr als genug. Trotz Big Brain passt irgendwann nicht mehr rein. Bomby. Bomby.
Okay, da musst du einfach nur lange spielen und Glück haben, dass das funktioniert. Deine Mutter. Oder was sagt der da? Hört sich immer an wie deine Mutter.
Mach's gut, Sebaro. Bomby, deine Mutter. Oh Mann, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Wollt ihr nicht besser Scavenger oder so? Okay, einfach Javelin in your face, Toppa-Gunner, fertig. Easy Nuke, easy life. Was? Bomby hat er jetzt geradgetwittert?
Dann haben wir Glück gehabt, dass das Ding nicht gegen die Decke geflogen ist.
Alter, er hat 5 Tage gespielt. Krass.
Da musst du halt echt Glück haben. Du musst halt 2 schöne Kills am Anfang hinkriegen, dass du direkt Harrier hast und mit dem Harrier kriegst du dann Toppa-Gunner und mit dem Toppa-Gunner kriegst du halt dann die Nuke. Ansonsten machst du da nicht so viel.
So viele Nukes kann man echt nur auf der Konsole machen. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Also ich meine mittlerweile schon, weil du Modern Warfare auf dem PC nicht mehr spielen kannst. Modern Warfare 2 richtig.
Auch modded, ja leider, leider.
Leider sind die alten Cod-Teile. Ich hab's ja mal ein bisschen probiert. Also Modern Warfare 2 hab ich gar nichts mehr gefunden.
Nuke ist 25 Kills.
Black Ops 1 hab ich noch ein bisschen was gefunden. Paar Free For Alls noch erspielt.
Aber der Sound vom Javelin find ich cool.
Ich glaube das war sehr frustrierend für ihn das zu erspielen.
Was? Keiner redet von Modern Warfare 2019?
Was? Nee, nee, nee.
Ja, 2019 ist es Gunstreak only 30 Kills und haben wir 2 mal halt 25 mit Killstreaks. Deswegen war es auch relativ einfach.
Was ist eigentlich Leute? Wisst ihr was aus alter EV-Net geworden ist beziehungsweise dem Nachfolger?
Es gab doch irgendeinen Nachfolger.
Greenstar 388, voll. EV-Net, ja. Spielen das noch viele?
EV-VX, okay. Ist das das mit NV-3-Waffen drinne?
Du, wir sind so nahe. Ich muss mich hier wieder aufhören, weil wenn ich auf der Map falle und 4 mehr Kills brauche...
Aber ja, wie ich schon gesagt habe, es ist, ich würde sagen, 100% unmöglich, 25 Gunstreaks mit einem Javelin nur zu bekommen.
Bist du selbst, mit dem Scavenger-Pack zu holen und zu suchen? Es ist einfach unmöglich.
Wenn ihr ein Video mit 25 Gunstreaks mit einem Javelin nur zu bekommen habt, dann geht das.
Vergesst es, vergesst es.
Das muss echt mega frustrierend gewesen sein, Javelin, Jungs.
Der sollte Javelin plus Noobtube-Nuke machen.
Ach, Knife ist erlaubt, okay.
Warum ist Knife erlaubt in einem Javelin-Owner-Nuke?
Und Claymore-Kills auch.
Bam, vorbei geschossen.
Der wird jetzt gekillt.
Scheiße.
Da kann man anlocken.
Die gehen auf die Fahne, oder?
Die sind rein rennen, die sind rein rennen.
Die Gegner, Alter.
Die MW42-Sekunden-Nuke-Nuke haben wir letztes Mal schon geguckt.
Der stirbt, der stirbt jetzt noch.
Nee, nee, der kriegt die Nuke. Der Video ist fast fertig.
Krass.
Sag mal, ist er gestorben, ist er gestorben gerade?
Bam, Boggers.
Krass, krass.
Deswegen gucke ich die Videos von ihm gerne.
Das ist keine große Show oder so, das zeigt einfach nur Gameplay.
Also Leute, falls ihr ihn noch nicht abonniert habt, abonniert ihn, das ist echt nice zu gucken.
Guck mal, Phanto ist am Start.
Was machen die Zähne, beziehungsweise, naja, Zähne ist falsch gesagt.
Was macht das übriggebliebene, wo die Zähne mal waren?
Und er hat gemessert, nur so ist legit Nuke, ne?
Also ihr erinnert euch noch in MW2.
Wer nicht gemessert hat zur Nuke, der hat die Nuke aberkannt bekommen.
Er hat einen Ticken zu früh gemessert.
Das müsste noch mal der Zentralrat der, keine Ahnung, Nuke-Überprüfer mal checken, ob das ein legit Nuke war, ohne das passende Messer-Timing.
Er hat schon über Stufe 1, abonniert 3 Monate, big brain sub, Poggers.
Muss mal gucken, ob ich Subs übersehen hab.
Leffa Lucky hatten wir schon und Daniel Lull davor hatten wir auch schon, perfekt, haben wir nichts übersehen.
Huge brain.
Leute, ich muss mal gucken, was mein Video macht, ob der Kram jetzt endlich verarbeitet ist.
Da wartet er mit 16 Uhr Zeit und er ist 360p.
Nice.
Warum ist YouTube eigentlich so langsam im Verarbeiten die letzten Tage?
Das ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
Ich hab gestern, vorgestern 3 Stunden gewartet, 4 Stunden gewartet auf ein Video, gestern 4 Stunden gewartet auf ein Video.
Und heute ist der Upload auch schon wieder ne Stunde fertig und tut sich nix.
Ok, heute versteh ich, weil das Video heute ist auch, wenn ich sag's euch, das Video heute ist ja auch 51 Minuten 30 Sekunden lang.
Alter, warum ist das so lang?
Nice.
Schade.
So Leute, sind wir wach?
Sind wir wach?
Hab ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt, was ihr tolles machen könnt?
Ich hab ja vorher schon mal angefangen, was ihr tolles machen könnt mit eurem Amazon Prime-Account.
Ja, 51 Minuten.
Da kann man schon mal nen Prime-Sub reinhauen, denk ich.
Für 51 Minuten Modern Warfare 2.
Äh, was sind 51 Minuten Modern Warfare 2009, Fazit.
Falls ihr nämlich nen Amazon-Account habt, könnt ihr das Ganze verbinden mit eurem Twitch-Account und einen Streamer eurer Wahl.
Also es muss nicht mich, muss nicht ich sein, ja.
Ihr könnt auch zum Fanto gehen oder zu irgendjemand anderem.
Und könnt ihr einmal im Monat kostenlos, also quasi auf Amazons Nacken, wie man heutzutage so schön sagt, einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem Tier-1-Sub unterstützen.
Das kostet euch nix.
Und ihr kriegt alle Vorteile, was Emotes und Sub-Badges und sowas angeht.
Und das Streamer auch.
Und ihr müsst dafür nix bezahlen.
Also ist Twitch-Prime-Sub verschimmeln lassen ist definitiv nicht Big Brain, sondern eher sehr Small Brain.
Und es möchte natürlich keiner Small Brain sein.
Horatius, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Ja, funktioniert schon.
So, ähm.
Eigentlich bin ich wach, Leute.
Wie sieht's bei euch so aus?
Seid ihr auch wach schon?
Nein.
Das ist Fangfrage, weil, weil wenn man sagt, ja, dann würde ja bedeutend, ich kann den Aufwachs-Stream ausmachen.
Ups.
Ich mein, wir waren heute ein bisschen später, wir waren heute ein bisschen später und sind vielleicht auch ein bisschen kürzer an.
Nur zwei, nur, nur, ja, nur zwei Stunden zwanzig.
Geht direkt über zum Mittagstream.
Ich muss meiner Katze jetzt was zu essen machen.
Ich glaub, die ist schon ganz schön angepisst, wenn ich jetzt hier gleich rausgehe aus meinem Arbeitszimmer.
Außerdem hab ich Hunger.
Das ist die Moab.
Okay, wir gucken mal, vielleicht empfiehlt uns YouTube irgendwas Gutes.
Cheap Lego Wheels Spins.
Der Aua hat ein neues Video, 500 Megahertz RAM.
Braucht das irgendjemand?
Abusing Unlimited Google Drive.
Okay, das hab ich schon mal irgendwann gesehen.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
60 Hertz versus 144 versus 240.
Die Wahrheit über Refresh Rate.
Okay, was ist das neueste Linux Tech Tips Videos?
Let's get this.
64-Core Epic.
Braucht kein Mensch.
Im Heimbereich.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Weil ihr wisst ja, ich halte das alles für unsinnig.
Weil es ist ja allgemein bekannt, wenn man da mal neuesten Studien glaubt, dass das menschliche Auge E012 FPS sieht.
Also alles unsinnig.
Und 24 halt mit zwei Augen.
Deswegen ist das alles unsinnig.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich den 144 bzw. auch 200-Hertz-Monitor hab, ist, weil ich gerne Geld ausgebe.
Bringen tut das nix.
Das ist genauso wie RGB.
RGB bringt ja auch nix, aber die Leute kaufen sich trotzdem RGB.
Starmag, zwei Monate, Porgas, danke.
Manche sehen auch 0 FPS aus beiden Augen.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage, ist das Auge kaputt?
Oder ist das Brain zu klein, um was zu sehen?
Das kann ja beides sein.
RGB bringt nichts.
Tja.
Die Wahrheit schmerzt manchmal, ja.
Das ist genauso, wie alles über 800 x 600 Auflösungen nix bringt.
Was meint ihr, warum die ganzen CSGO Pros in so komischen Auflösungen spielen?
Einfach heute einfach mal Realtalk, ich sag, wie es ist, ja.
Höhere Auflösung ist umsonst und mehr als 12 FPS ist auch umsonst.
Okay, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Hey, sitzt wirklich irgendjemand so vorm Monitor und spielt Overwatch?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Niemand sitzt so vorm Rechner und spielt Overwatch.
Das ist ja fast so wie dieser Typ.
Okay, nicht ganz so schlimm, ja.
Alter Leute, ihr diskutiert jetzt nicht ernsthaft drüber, ob das stimmt, was ich glaube.
Mit 12 FPS im Chat, oder?
Ich dachte, wir haben High IQ Chat.
Das ist ja Wahnsinns-Pepega-Diskussion, ey.
Sorry.
Ah.
Sellout-Video.
So nennt man das also.
Teamed up with Nvidia.
Das ist kein Sponsored-Video, er ist nur team-upped mit Nvidia.
Das sag ich das nächste Mal auch so.
Ich sag das nächste Mal nicht gesponsored von Ubisoft, gesponsored von Nvidia oder sowas.
Ich denk mir da irgendwie ein bisschen schönere Umschreibung aus.
Ja.
So nach dem Motto, ich hab mich mit Ubisoft zusammengesetzt und das neueste Ubisoft ge-
Egal.
Der muss aber seine Überleitung noch ein bisschen üben.
Vor allem, vor allem es tiert, es tiert wie Sau, guckt euch das mal an.
Guck mal an, es tiert wie Sau.
Was ist mit dem Reifen los?
Mach doch erst mal, mach doch Motion Blur erst mal aus.
Ist so.
Was ist mit dem Reifen los?
Riesenunterschied, ja klar.
Es ist trotzdem ein Unterschied.
Wie geht Battlefield 5?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also hier am Gamingrechner habe ich einen BenQ 104 Jets Monitor dran, ich habe keine Ahnung welches Modell genau, ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Oh ne, jetzt komm mir nicht mit dieser Nvidia Studie, da habe ich doch schon mal ein Video zugemacht.
Jetzt komm mir nicht damit, wo Nvidia rausgefunden hat, je teurer die Nvidia Grafikkarte ist und umso besser sind die Leute.
Nein, nicht unbedingt, nein eigentlich solltest du den Gegner nicht unbedingt, kommt auf das Game an, du solltest den Gegner nicht unbedingt schneller sehen,
du hast den größten Vorteil, dass die Bewegung weicher ist, dass du in der Bewegung, wenn du dich drehst, dass du mehr siehst vom Spiel in der Bewegung und dass es sich einfach flüssiger anfühlt.
Was natürlich auch ein riesen Vorteil ist, was du merkst beim Zielen, es ist halt ein Unterschied, ob dein Maus Input 144 Mal in der Sekunde abgedatet werden kann im Game grafisch oder nur 60 Mal,
dass du Gegner früher oder später siehst, das hängt wahrscheinlich vom Game, aber würde ich so generell nicht unterschreiben.
Ich meine theoretisch vielleicht schwankt das mal um ein paar Frames, aber an sich eigentlich nicht.
Weil ich meine der Gegner sollte zur gleichen Zeit auf deinem Bildschirm auftauchen.
Maus Input ist an die Frame Rate gebunden.
Naja logischerweise ja, also nicht wie das Ingame abtastet deine Maus, aber dass es angezeigt wird ist natürlich an die Frame Rate gebunden.
Wenn ich meine Maus jetzt wild hin und her bewege, wird das mit 144 öfters updatet als mit 60, was ich merke Ingame.
Dementsprechend fühlt es sich ja auch viel kontrollierter an mit 144 Hz als mit 60.
Das reine abtasten von der Maus, das ist nicht an meine FPS gebunden, aber das was das Spiel rendert natürlich.
Du hast einfach weniger in der Bewegung, weil du halt mehr Bilder zur Verfügung hast.
Ist deine Maus Abtastrate 500 oder 1000? Ich glaube 1000, warte mal, kann ich dir sagen, 1000.
Ich verwende eh nur 800 DPI, ich weiß gar nicht warum der überhaupt eingestellt ist.
Maus invertieren, nee Maus invertieren suckt, Controller invertieren ist big brain.
Maus invertieren machen nur die Noobs, Controller invertieren machen die richtig guten Spieler.
Ja das bringt es aber bei hoher Frames jetzt nur bedingt.
Trotzdem bringt es was.
Das mit dem Controller ist nicht ernst gemeint, ich spiele halt Controller nur invertiert.
Fairness 990 sagt, wer die Abtastrate von der Maus niedriger stellt als das Maximum, das möglich ist, ist ein richtiges big brain.
Ja ist es tatsächlich, weil wenn du beispielsweise deine Maus an der PS4 anschließt, die ja irgendwie suckt über USB, ist die Abtastrate tatsächlich sinnvoller runterzustellen.
Die Maus, ich habe es ja mit Modern Warfare auf der PS4 ausprobiert, stellt man die Abtastrate auf 250 oder was, 250 runter? Muss ich mal gucken.
Also stellt man die, genau 125, aber die Abtastrate auf 250 hat sich die Maus auf der PS4 viel besser gespielt als auf 1000. Aber das ist hier eine PS4 Geschichte.
Warum invertiert man seinen Controller? Weil ich damit besser spielen kann.
Nicht Abtastrate, Polling Rate, also ja, ne damit ist nicht DPI gemeint, damit ist gemein im Endeffekt, wie oft die Maus, wie oft von der Mausänderung abgefragt werden.
Oder geliefert werden.
Ich weiß gar nicht wer da wen pollt ehrlich gesagt.
Immer.
Also ich kaufe mir den nächsten 240 Hertz Monitor.
Also ich wollte mir den nächsten 240 holen, weiß nur noch nicht welchen.
Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob 1440 oder 1080p.
Wahrscheinlich 1080p, weil ich relativ dicht vor dem Monitor sitze.
Und man eh scheiß Quali-Settings braucht für 240 FPS.
Ich hab irgendeinen Benky 144 Hertz, ich weiß nicht wie der heißt.
Ehh, Cotton Cori doch. Klar, kommst du auf 240 FPS. Du musst einfach die Quali runterstellen. Deswegen spiele ich ja alle Online-Games immer in Augenkrebsqualität.
Dass ich viel FPS habe. FPS Beste.
Was gibt es denn da gerade so? Ja okay wir haben es verstanden. Was gibt es denn da gerade so? Was lohnt sich denn da gerade?
Was sagt denn PC Games Hardware zu? Den traue ich da immer ganz gut zu.
Kaufberatung. Gucken wir nochmal.
Wo sind die Monitore?
Ahja, der passt doch.
21 zu 9, 21 zu 9 brauch ich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ich finde, dass G-Sync jetzt nicht so der krasse Gamechanger ist, was draus gemacht wird bei hohen Framerates. Hält sich finde ich in Grenzen. Ich hab meinen G-Sync Monitor sogar verkauft vor einer Weile.
Ich hatte ja einen G-Sync Monitor. Das Problem war von AOC oder so. Den habe ich damals von Nvidia gekriegt und der war gut. Der hat mir im Prinzip besser gefallen als mein BenQ Monitor.
Die Sache dabei war bloß, die Farben bei dem Ding sahen so kacke aus. Ich bin ja auch jemand, der seinen Monitor kalibriert. Big Brain Move.
Übrigens, wer sich fragt, wie man ein Monitor kalibriert. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es jetzt was Neues gibt.
Da könnt ihr euch sowas hier kaufen.
Die Seite lädt nicht wirklich. Das ist so ein Ding, das hängt dir vor dem Monitor, schließt ein paar USB an. Dann zeigt es halt verschiedene Farben im Hintergrund an. Das Ding misst, wie die Farben aussehen. Und dann kommt ein Farbprofil raus, das mit dem ihr euren Monitor kalibrieren könnt.
Das ist wirklich nice. Und ich habe versucht, das Ding zu kalibrieren, diesen G-Sync Monitor, den ich hatte. Das sah scheiße aus. Wenn du gute Farben haben willst, ist es 240Hz.
Ich brauche keine Topfarben. Ich brauche Farben, wo rot nach rot wenigstens aussieht. Und gelb nicht nach blau und sowas. Und eher nicht nach grün.
Ich bin da gar nicht so anspruchsvoll. Deswegen kalibriere ich die Dinge, dass sie halbwegs in die Richtung kommen. Und das Ding war so schlecht von den Farben her. Das konnte ich mit kalibrieren nicht mal richtig verwenden.
Das habe ich dann verkauft.
Okay, also was empfiehlt uns denn PC Games Hardware?
Geht das auch für den TV? Ja klar.
Du musst dann bloß gucken. Es gibt zwei Varianten. Du kannst entweder mit einem Farbprofil kalibrieren. Wobei wahrscheinlich beim Fernsehen kannst du kein Farbprofil laden.
Aber du kannst auch kalibrieren mit dem Ding. Und halt immer wieder laufen lassen und die Farben kontrollieren und dann am Fernsehen rumstellen. Das geht auch.
Also ich denke auch, bei hohen Frames ist G-Sync nicht so das Ding. Wahrscheinlich wird der nächste Monitor, den ich mir hole, tatsächlich wieder G-Sync haben. Weil die meisten mittlerweile sowas haben.
Der A-Org. Freesync. Kann ein Video jetzt eigentlich auf Freesync oder kann nur AMD Freesync? Ja. Beide. Ui. Na Gott sei Dank.
Hi FPS Gaming. Zwei sind auf dem Markt. Jawoll. Auf Kosten der Bildqualität.
Wie Sync? Welche Inputlag erhöhen? Ja ok. Wenn sich Grafikkarte und Monitor synchronisieren, wann welches Bild ausgeschickt wird, habe ich mir nie Gedanken zu gemacht. Ich glaube nicht, dass es zu Inputlag führt, den man fühlen kann.
Ok. Was empfehlen Sie denn da? Moin AC DX. Was empfehlen Sie hier?
Haben die auch ne Tabelle? Rauschunterdrückung für Mikrofone. IGIT! Also erstens, warum habe ich den Monitor mit Rauschunterdrückung für Mikrofone? Und warum habe ich den Mikrofon, wo ich überhaupt Rausch unterdrücken muss?
Rauschunterdrückung Leute. Das brauchst du nur, wenn du irgendwelchen Audio Bullshit Gamer Zeug kaufst. Dann brauchst du Rauschunterdrückung. So was blödsinniges.
Ok. Also die sagen, der ist relativ gut. KD25F. Kostet 550 Euro. Oh, das ist von MSI gewesen, oder? Von MSI habe ich keine... ach nee Gigabit. Ok. Gigabyte.
Da hätte ich vielleicht sogar ne Chance, wenn ich da rum nerfe, dass man da irgendwie mal eine... wie hat er gesagt? Dass ich mit den Team Uppen könnte und den Monitor zeigen.
Mit MSI habe ich keine Chancen, weil MSI hat mich gebannt. Und ich weiß, ich erzähl's ja immer wieder, aber ich weiß bis heute nicht warum.
Hier gibt's die offizielle Nvidia Liste. Also gut, das war ich dich bestimmt nicht für. Ok, also der ist anscheinend nicht schlecht, wenn ich das so sehe. Was kostet der auf Amazon?
Liefer nach Oberursel, ja auf geht's. Ähm... Moment, ist das ein anderer?
Adi? Ist das ein anderer? Hä?
Ja, warum die Namen von Monitoren so beknackt sind, weiß ich auch nicht. Mittlerweile sind aber weitere Modelle. Der Asus ROG Swift.
Gibt es eigentlich... Gibt es 240Hz mit 1044p? Warum hatte ich MSI? Ich weiß es nicht.
Gibt es nur Full HD? Offiziell ist es Batman. Dann gucken wir uns mal die offizielle Nvidia Spec Liste an.
Ist das Eis? Nein, das braucht keiner. Kann man das nicht sortieren? Hier! Ah! Refresh Rate! Komm an, Bra! Refresh Rate!
Ok, 240. Gibt's da irgendwas? Nein, gibt's nicht. Dann wird's wieder in Full HD. Dann wird's wieder in Full HD.
Das einzige, was es als Alternative gäbe, wären 165Hz. Nee, ich upgrade nicht von einem 144Hz Monitor Full HD auf einen weiteren Full HD.
Also mir ist mehr FPS bzw. mehr Herz ist mir da wichtiger.
Ja, aber ich will keinen 144Hz. Das Wichtige ist auf jeden Fall, 240Hz will ich haben.
Kommt wieder Kaufberatungsvideo, weiß ich nicht. Mal gucken. Vielleicht mach ich mit Hardware Rat was zur Weihnachten.
Lenovo Legion? Die Dinger haben Namen, Alter! Wer denkt sich das aus? Easy! 1634€!
Haben wir noch ein paar Prime Subs am Start? Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen teuer, das ganze Ding. Ein Schnapper, ja.
1000€! Das ist mir dann doch ein bisschen teurer. Dafür würde ich mir schon eher diesen 4K 144Hz Monitor von Asus kaufen, der eine Lüfter braucht.
Aber das klingt doch eigentlich wie ein ganz guter Gesamtpaket hier. Also ich will wieder einen 24Hz. Mein Schreibtisch ist jetzt nicht so tief und ich sitze relativ nah am Monitor.
Alles was größer wird, sehe ich, wenn ich unten links hingucke, nicht mehr oben rechts. 24Hz ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ok, also dann haben wir hier noch einen Asus ROG Swift. Was kostet der? Ok, das kostet alles um so 500€. Gucken wir mal bei Geizhals.
Die Call of Duty Black Ops Edition. Das ist vielleicht sogar Big Brain Move, sich jetzt die Black Ops 4 Edition zu kaufen, weil den will keiner mehr haben.
Ah ne, doch. Naja, 528€, das geht doch.
Du hast ja eine Vorliebe bei den Panels. Naja, mir wird für 240€ bei nichts anderes als TN Panel übrig bleiben. Ich bin aber auch, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin nicht so der Riesen Monitor Pro, was die Technik da angeht. Ich kenne mich da nicht so gut aus.
Das Einzige, was ich halt immer mache mit meinen Monitors, die werden einmal kalibriert, dass die Farben wenigstens halbwegs gescheit aussehen, aber das war's.
Also, was kriegen wir denn für 528€? Da gucken wir uns mal ein Review an.
Haben die bestimmt ein Review. Da.
Asus ROG Swift. Die Namen von den Dingern immer, Alter.
Bildqualität und Fazit. Asus ROG Swift PG258Q. Warum haben Monitore eigentlich immer so total bescheuerte Namen?
Ok. Bildqualität.
Qualität TN Panels haben sich letztes Jahr, ok, das ist doch schon mal schön.
Ok, der hat sogar gute Farbwerte.
Ja gut, Fernseher haben, vor allem Sony Fernseher haben auch wirre Namen. 22Hz flüssige Bildwiedergabe, der sagt, ab 22Hz wird es ansatzweise flüssig empfunden.
Und nicht als Einzelbilder, das heißt nicht, dass es flüssig ist.
Trotz hoffnungslos überdimensionierten Leuchtdichte ist die Ausleucht der Bildfläche recht gleichmäßig. Ok.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut, da guckst du nicht unten und oben hin und unten brauchst du Sonnenbrille und oben, ne.
Input lag. Der Input lag messen wir mit einem kleinen Apparat, der englische.
Ist jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Hä?
Ok, der Absatz ist mir zu big brain. Ist es jetzt gut oder schlecht, was der für Input lag hat?
Egal.
Für immer bessere TN Qualität, die EPS Mittelklasse wird schmaler. Ok.
Ok.
Das klingt auch gar nicht schlecht.
Warum sind 144 FPS nicht genug, 144 FPS sind genug, aber warum sollte man sich mit 144 zufriedengeben, wenn man auch 240 haben kann?
Oder?
Den Asus Gold mit G-Sync, meinst du den, den ich mir gerade angeguckt habe?
Achso, PS, nicht FPS, da ist es ja genauso.
Wie lang bin ich jetzt eigentlich schon an? Mal gucken. Ich muss mal echt langsam was essen Leute, ich hab übelst Kohldampf.
Aber der Monitor macht einen guten Eindruck. Vielleicht, vielleicht hol ich mir den.
Was, den AW2-Ding-Spa? Ok, Review PC. PC Gems hat was für beste, beste Review.
Ach, das ist ein Alienware, nee Alienware bekomm ich mir nicht.
Alienware ist irgendwie so ein Hersteller, hab ich gewisse Abneigung dagegen. Aber vielleicht ist der ganz gut. Kann er sein, vielleicht ist der echt ganz gut.
Nee, das ist Forum, ne?
Bei Alienware nicht HP, nee HP ist Omen, Dell, genau Wouts, Dell ist das.
Ja, das ist auch eine Alternative. Der hier, der ist auch cool. Aber der ist halt ein bisschen teuer.
Wenn ich in Richtung Auflösung gehen würde, würde ich mir das hier holen. Allerdings nicht für den Preis, ne?
Das ist quasi ein 4K, der 144Hz kann. Das heißt im Zweifelsfall kannst du sagen, ich spiele einfach auf niedrigerer Auflösung.
Wenn ich 144Hz wähle um Desktopbetrieb mache ich 4K. Das ist eigentlich ein Monitor, den ich mir schon lange gewünscht habe, sowas.
Aber es ist mir trotzdem ein bisschen teuer, ehrlich gesagt. Nichts, was man sich nicht kaufen könnte, aber ich sehe es irgendwo nicht ein.
Ich sehe es nicht ein, 2000 Euro, 2300 Euro auszugeben für eben ein Monitor. Das muss echt nicht sein.
500 Euro ist okay, aber 2300 muss echt nicht sein.
Wir könnten uns dafür auch einen iMac holen für 15000 Euro.
Okay Leute, schön, dass ihr alle dabei gewesen seid. Ich muss jetzt unbedingt was futtern. Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Wir sehen uns beim Video heute. Mal gucken, ob das verarbeitet ist. Ich schau mal schnell, ob es verarbeitet ist.
Big Brain Video Verarbeitung. Wie sieht es aus? Und nein, es ist noch nicht verarbeitet. Ich hoffe, dass es bis 16 Uhr oder so wenigstens fertig verarbeitet ist.
Schauen wir mal. Ich gehe jetzt was futtern, Leute. Macht es gut. Ich mache jetzt keine Einschlafmusik, weil es war eine Aufwachs-Stream.
Also ich denke mal, es kommt wahrscheinlich Raid zu German. Könnte man echt machen. Das da oder das da? Das da.
Okay, also Leute, hausen wir ein paar Speedrunner. Wir sehen uns. Macht es gut. Bis dann. See you.
So funktioniert das mit Raiden, okay. Poggers. Bis dann. Macht es gut.